secuencia terminado esta reunión con
esta opositora el jefe de la diplomacia
europea joseph murray ha asegurado que
son necesarias nuevas elecciones en el
país recordemos la unión europea nos
reconoce el resultado nos reconoce a
lukashenko como presidente de
bielorrusia y por lo tanto pide que lo
importante es que haya un diálogo
nacional y sobre todo que haya paz
y se solucione la situación en el país
aún así aún de momento no hay sanciones
tal y como lleva desde hace un mes la
unión europea intentando aprobar porque
las decisiones sobre diplomacia tienen
que ser por unanimidad y de momento no
se ha conseguido unanimidad para que
haya sanciones en el país han debido a
que ahora mismo chipre bloquea estas
sanciones debido entre otras cuestiones
a la situación con turquía y la
extracción de hidrocarburos ilegal en el
mar de chipre